THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
OH, THANK YOU!
(CHANTING)
THANK YOU!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
WELCOME TO "THE NIGHTLY SHOW I'M
YOUR HOST, LARRY, LARRY, LARRY,
(LAUGHTER)
BEFORE WE GET GOING, LAST NIGHT
WAS THE SUPER BOWL,
CONGRATULATIONS PATIOTS
I'M GLAD YOU WON. AND I'M A
SEAHAWKS FAN.
I REALLY SLAMMED THE PATS ON
THURSDAY'S SHOW.
I MEAN, I HIT YOUR TEAM LIKE THE
WICKED HAHD.
AND THEN I PUT THIS ONLINE.
IF THE PATRIOTS WIN, I WILL EAT
A BOWL OF, WHATEVER YOU CALL IT,
NEW ENGLAND CLAM CHOWDER.
THERE YOU GO.
YEP.
SO I'M A MAN OF MY WORD.
I'VE GOT A BIG BOWL OF
NEW ENGLAND CLAM CHOWDER.
THIS LOOKS PRETTY GOOD,
ACTUALLY.
SHOULD I GET SOME CRACKERS?
NAH, I'LL JUST EAT IT.
MMM!
VERY GOOD!
THAT'S NOT "CHEATING," PATRIOTS
FANS.
I JUST DEFLATED THE SIZE OF THE
BOWL SO IT'S EASIER TO GRIP.
BAM!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HORRIBLE! WICKED HAHD
THE ONLY THING WORSE THAN THE
GAME WAS THE COMMERCIALS.
>> I COULDN'T GROW UP 'CUZ I
DIED FROM AN ACCIDENT.
>> Larry: JESUS!
I WANTED TO WATCH A FOOTBALL
GAME.
I DIDN'T KNOW I HAD TO PREPARE A
EULOGY FOR A CHILD.
I WAS ALREADY FEELING CRAPPY
ENOUGH FROM EATING MY FAMOUS
SEVEN-LAYER CORN-TITO DOUBLE-DIP
BACON DEEP-FRIED SOUR
CREAM-STUFFED CRUST PANINI.
TRADEMARK!
DON'T ACT LIKE IT WAS JUST ME.
YOU GUYS HAD YOUR BUTTON POPPED
BY HALFTIME.
ON SUPER BOWL SUNDAY, AMERICANS
CONSUMED ROUGHLY 1.25 BILLION
CHICKEN WINGS,
11.2 MILLION-POUND OF POTATO
CHIPS, AND 49.2 MILLION CASES OF
BEER.
SUCK ON THAT, THIRD WORLD!
U.S.A.!
(AUDIENCE CHANTING)
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT THE TIME TO
CHANT.
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY.
AMERICA, I THINK IT'S TIME FOR
AN INTERVENTION.
YOU FAT.
SERIOUSLY, GALLUP JUST RELEASED
THE OBESITY STATS FOR 2014, AND
THE NUMBERS SPIKED TO 27.7%.
NEARLY A THIRD OF OUR COUNTRY IS
OBESE.
NOW, I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE A
JOKE ABOUT THAT.
THE LAST THING WE SHOULD BE
DOING IS MAKING FUN OF FAT
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW IN THIS TIME OF
OBVIOUS CRISIS.
AND I CONDEMN ANYONE OUT THERE
MAKING CHEAP FAT JOKES.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE UPSET AT
MICHAEL MOORE FOR THROWING SHADE
AT SNIPERS, BUT IN ALL FAIRNESS,
HE THROWS SHADE ON EVERYTHING IN
HIS IMMEDIATE VICINITY.
YEAH, I KNOW.
I'M SORRY.
BUT EVERYONE CAN MAKE A MISTAKE
ONCE.
"TOP GUN" TAUGHT US THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR VETS,
BECAUSE SOME OUR SOLDIERS AGE
WELL AND SOME DON'T.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
LOOKS LIKE THE ICE MAN BECAME
THE ICE CREAM MAN.
OKAY.
GUILTY AS CHARGED.
IN LIGHT OF THIS NEW
INFORMATION, I JUST NOW RELEASED
THIS STATEMENT.
I AM TERRIBLY ASHAMED OF MY
COMMENTS.
THEY WERE MADE IN A MOMENT OF
WEAKNESS UPON SEEING VAL
KILMER'S FACE.
HE REALLY LET HIMSELF GO.
BUT THAT IS NO EXCUSE FOR MAKING
FUN OF HIM.
I MAKE NO APOLOGIZE FOR MY
STATEMENTS REGARDING MICHAEL
MOORE'S SHADOW, HOWEVER.
THAT'S JUST SCIENCE.
(APPLAUSE)
OBESITY IS CLEARLY A PROBLEM
HERE IN THE U.S., BUT WHAT ABOUT
THE REST OF THE WORLD?
>> EUROPE'S HIGHEST COURT HAS
RULED THAT OBESITY CAN CAN, IN
CERTAIN CASES, BE CONSIDERED A
DISABILITY.
>> MY EYEBROWS ARE UP HERE.
>> Larry: CALM DOWN, BRITISH
DON LEMON.
OKAY, SO SO OBESITY IS A
DISABILITY IN EUROPE.
BUT SO IS WORKING.
AND BATHING.
BOOM!
I'M SORRY!
I KNOW I SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID
THAT.
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
OKAY.
I HAVE JUST RELEASED AN APOLOGY
TO THE BRITISH PEOPLE.
I WOULD LIKE TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
BRITISH PEOPLE.
THAT WAS COMPLETELY OUT OF LINE.
I STILL MAKE NO APOLOGIES FOR MY
STATEMENTS ABOUT MICHAEL MOORE'S
SHADOW, HOWEVER.
THAT'S STILL JUST SCIENCE.
(APPLAUSE)
SO, IN EUROPE, OBESITY HAS BEEN
CLASSIFIED AS A DISABILITY.
THAT'S NOT HOW WE PLAY IN
AMERICA.
>> THE HOSPITAL'S INSTITUTING A
HIRING POLICY THAT EXCLUDES
OVERWEIGHT CANDIDATES.
OVERWEIGHT PILOTS WITH A BMI OF
AT LEAST 40 OR WITH A NECK
THAT'S AT LEAST 17 INCHES MUST
BE EVALUATED.
>> WAITRESSES CAN BE FIRED FOR
GAINING MORE THAN 7% OF THEIR
ORIGINAL BODY WEIGHT.
>> OVERWEIGHT WOMEN EARN SMALLER
PAYCHECKS THAN AVERAGE SIZE
WOMEN.
>> Larry: OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YO MOMMA'S SO FAT -- OKAY, YO
MOMMA'S SO FAT, SHE SUFFERS FROM
SYSTEMIC BIAS IN A JOB MARKET
THAT MARGINALIZES HER JUST BASED
ON HER APPEARANCE.
OHHHHHH!
(APPLAUSE)
AND IT DOESN'T END THERE.
IN MOST OF THE COUNTRY, YOU CAN
STILL FIRE SOMEONE FOR BEING
OBESE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE UNEMPLOYED,
YOU'RE LIKELY TO GAIN MORE
WEIGHT, MAKING IT HARDER TO FIND
A JOB.
IT'S A VICIOUS SOUL CYCLE OF
INJUSTICE.
SO IF WE'RE ACTIVELY
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST OBESE
PEOPLE, IT BRINGS UP THE
QUESTION:  SHOULD OBESITY BE
TREATED AS A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE?
I GET IT.
IT'S TOUGH BEING OVERWEIGHT IN
TODAY'S SOCIETY.
MAGAZINES, TELEVISION AND
MOVIES ARE FULL OF IMAGES OF A
THIN PERSON HAVING GOOD STUFF
HAPPEN TO THEM.
EVEN IF YOU GO TO CHURCH, YOU
SEE A P90X VERSION OF JESUS ON
THE CROSS.
RIGHT?
(LAUGHTER)
TALK ABOUT CROSS-FIT.
AM I RIGHT?
AM I RIGHT, CHRISTIAN LADIES?
OKAY.
I'D LIKE TO ISSUE AN APOLOGY TO
MY CHRISTIAN LADIES.
MY MOCKERY OF JESUS, THOUGH
ACCURATE, WAS WAY OUT OF LINE.
UNLIKE THE MICHAEL MOORE BLAH
BLAH BLAH, ET AL.
MY POINT IS, IF JESUS LOOKED
LIKE THIS, MORE GALIFIANAKIS
THAN CAVIEZEL, MAYBE WE WOULDN'T
HEAR PEOPLE -- IN THIS CASE, A
POLITICIAN -- FINDING THIS AS
THE CAUSE OF ERIC GARNER'S
DEATH.
>> YOU HAD A 350-POUND PERSON
WHO WAS RESISTING ARREST.
IF HE HAD NOT HAD ASTHMA AND A
HEART CONDITION AND WAS SO
OBESE, ALMOST DEFINITELY HE
WOULD NOT HAVE DIED.
>> Larry: WOW.
(BOOING)
LOOK, I'M NOT SURE IF OBESITY IS
A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE, BUT I'M
SURE OF ONE THING -- THE WAY
WE'RE TREATING OBESE PEOPLE, IT
AIN'T RIGHT.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.